if you're with us yesterday you know
that I went off on a tangent I was
watching Jerry Maguire and then I
started to wonder as I'm watching the
movie why did Jerry have to get fired
there now the mission statement I get it
you know less glance less money so I
sent the Dennett's a text last night
before I said why did Jerry Maguire have
to get fired and then they didn't say
anything and then they said let's
discuss it on the show and then all of a
sudden Fritzi started reaching out to
some people who are in the movie
including the great Cameron Crowe who
wrote the movie writer producer director
camera and III don't know if it came out
of nowhere
since it's been out for 20 years but
that's why we reached out to you so
thanks for joining us okay what what's
the number one question you get about
Jerry Maguire 20 years later a lot of
what was Tom Cruise like no a lot of you
know show me the money
questions and stuff like that I'm just
glad that people are still kind of
psyched about the movie I just saw it on
a big screen again the other day for the
first time in a long time so I'm fresh
what do we not know about the casting
there tell me something about who you
went for and you know having Tom Cruise
sign on had to be had to be huge but how
was the casting planting you know it was
originally written with Tom Hanks
and by the time it was you know it had
arrived at the point where he had to say
yes he would do it I had this he read
the script and I had this wonderful
conversation with Tom Hanks and people
were waiting in the next room for for
the answer and Tom Hanks was so
complimentary it's so great and said you
know I'd love to do this but I'm doing
that thing you do I just be doing that
instead of this movie but good luck I
was so like high on the Tom Hanks
personality charisma that I walked into
the next Truman I just had the greatest
conversation with Tom Hanks
and and I frankly always had Tom Cruise
in my mind as encased Tom Hanks bailout
which was always gonna be a possibility
and we sent it to Tom and Tom instantly
read it called and said you know I'm a
sports guy I love this how about if I
fly to you and read it for you can you
tell me if I'm right for it which was
amazing so he's basically saying I'll
audition the part where you tell me if
you want to hire me so from that moment
on how important is Renee Zellweger not
really being on you know the national
landscape there that to sort of play the
role of Dorothy the accountant who just
sort of floats in to his life and then
you realize how important she is but we
didn't know who she was how important is
that for that role great question and
it's so cool that she was kind of an
unknown person because it helped Tom be
Jerry Maguire instead of like a Tom
Cruise character in a movie filled with
people you know it was kind of like a
guy you know filled you know surrounded
with new faces and so Renee came in a
couple of times
Tom was there and they had an incident
and so we knew this is the right track
to me and she was a little nervous
because it was her first big movie but I
think all of that worked for the
character and I loved Bonnie Hunt I
thought that she was who she was just so
sneaky great in there and also J Moore I
felt like Jay Mohr was playing J Moore
as Bob sugar would yeah was that is that
the role that you saw for J Moore J
Moore first came in for a couple other
parts one of them was first for I
believe which didn't feel right but he
was always funny and we tried him out
for Bob sugar and there's a thing on the
blu-ray where you see like minute take
where he's just taking phone calls
caring Jerry Maguire apart his clients
but also the firing scene though Cameron
yeah Jay told us that when he I think
Cruz paused for like 15 or 20 seconds
and then that's that's where Jay says
say say something this is real Jerry was
that scripted yeah that was scripted but
I think everybody everybody wasn't sure
if Jay had forgotten the line or not the
great thing is that that Cruz's is so
generous as a guy when Cuba just started
like dubbing him out of the frame and
scenes and like berating him and Jay
more like tearing him to pieces Cruz
would be like bring it there's a
fantastic like the more I'm a loser the
better this movie is gonna be and and it
was great I got to tell you one thing
Dan I'm very proud of Glenn Frey playing
Dennis Wilburn in the movie and you did
that great interview with Glenn Frey
that I was last time I talked to Glenn
we talked about your interview and he
was really proud of it very jazzed that
I had seen it so Bravo Bravo thank you
thank you
we loved when he came into the room and
in our New York mancave like he knew the
show knew the dance and just like the it
was just different when certain guys
come in the room he Glenn Frey walks
into the room and you go damn that's
Glenn Frey the Eagles walking into the
room yeah couldn't have been nicer I
also like when I'm watching the movie
the other night I see yon winner up
there who was you know the creator of
Rolling Stone magazine but what made you
cast yon winner in there I would love
that yarn as a head of Rolling Stone he
inspired like you know both loyal and
ferocious play among his his people you
know so he would inspire he would
inspire everybody to like work harder
and he also had a great kind of stake
you know and I thought like it's like
watching Terry implode it's looking down
from the upper tier
which he did just like I thought he
might so it's also cool when you throw
people into a movie that that are
unlikely you know like Jerry Cantrell
from Alice in Chains plays the guy who
looks at who's the copy man guy that
like copy Jerry's mission tonight and I
just love Tom Cruise and Jerry from that
may not happen again for a while he's
Cameron Crowe the writer director
producer actor Jerry Maguire almost
famous ok Fast Times at Ridgemont High
help help me here with the Phoebe Cage
scene ok does she actually walk in on
Judge Reinhold in does he have a prop in
his hand in the bathroom as she gets out
of the pool with her top off at least in
judge's mind
yes he does Dan okay and there was one
take that the director Amy Heckerling
did just for the studio where the camera
panned down the judge let's just say he
was holding a rather large accessory
that didn't make it into the movie but
you got Phoebe is that her genuine
reaction in that scene the one that you
used anyway yeah yeah I mean it was the
second day that we were filming and
judge came out of the bathroom and I
remember he said my first big love scene
how true is almost famous to to your
life that's my mom
you know like in almost every way except
she says I would never my mom says I
would never be barefoot in the house
everything else is accurate and the band
that you followed was well that's a
combination that's a that's a
combination probably have Led Zeppelin
Lynyrd Skynyrd's the Eagles and Neil
Young and it's actually Glenn who said
to me when I was writing about the
Eagles your
mr. fry and it just make just make us
look cool and how old are you at the
time 16 what do you remember about
Zeppelin you know the greatest shows
probably still that I've that I've ever
seen although My Morning Jacket is kind
of like inspiring and you know unplanned
improv type stuff that my morning
jacket's always been really good but
Zeppelin in the day they never put out
ads there was never any any indication
they were going to be in your town
except if you were a fan and you do and
so those shows obviously with no video
assists or any big big huge light shows
you know they they would just play and
sometimes you know Jimmy Page would go
off and do like a 45-minute version of
Dazed and Confused he just felt like
every show as a fan you know it's
different and Pearl Jam does that to you
no there's no plan setlist night tonight
so you're always going to be surprised
Zeppelin was very you know dark exciting
and very vibe it's a wonderful yeah I
did a nice small Zeppelin in the 70s and
I remember when John Bonham did like his
solo on Moby Dick and then I like I
didn't get it at the time like oh damn
here's 27 minutes I'm not going to get
back yes yes yeah plant plant had to
make sure his genes were even tighter
but but watching but watching them I
mean it wasn't a stage show where as I
went to see Pink Floyd when they did the
animals tour and all of a sudden you got
these durables you got these animals
floating around right and I went oh my
god this is sensory over let's the first
concert I remember I went to yeah I went
oh my god and I saw the stones when they
had the phallic come out of the stage
when Jagger was dressed is the
Philadelphia Eagle that was another one
where I went oh my god this is this is a
little bit different than seeing you
know Zeppelin or Aerosmith well it's
when it started to become more of an
Enter
experience it as opposed to an actual
concert and you know both are great but
Zeppelin I know are always very much
about that their performance and if you
were there it was like you were sharing
some private thing that happened between
fans in the band and they were in in at
that time when you saw him in the 70s
and stuff they were not Zeppelin as has
to be loved Led Zeppelin that they are
today they were kind of the bad boys
everybody was talking more about the
Rolling Stones but quietly Led Zeppelin
was out there destroying audiences for
years and then of course ascended to the
place they are now in say anything when
you when you use the song in your eyes
was there a was there another that was
the only song you had when Cusack's
holding up his boom box yeah that's the
that song you had in mind when you you
put that scene together no no not at all
in fact that was that was like that was
a scene that was not working at all John
Cusack is a big fan of his abandon me to
fishbone so Hugh sack is actually
playing this song boning in the boneyard
is romantic though powerful romantic
scene but he looks like he's a stalker
playing fishbone outside a little bit
you know and every song we tried didn't
work it was just kind of ridiculous and
and we even had some songwriters come in
and write a song and that was not where
it was the fight listen to me outside
your window we're like no no that's not
that's not working and I was driving to
the editing room one day and I had this
playlist of stuff from my wedding and in
your eyes was on it and in your eyes
came out of my car and it's like wait a
minute
all these lyrics sound like the scene oh
my god I said I raised him to the
editing room we tried it it was the song
we needed to use and then there was a
huge kind of scary negotiation get the
song because Peter Gabriel originally
didn't
have it used in any movie that was its
own little battle but once everything
straightened out we were so grateful
because that's the only song that worked
at that scene let me go back to Jerry
Maguire because you bring up music he
just comes back from talking to cush and
he's he's got the number-one draft pick
he's in the car he's pressing the
buttons he's got different songs but he
all of a sudden decides to stay on free
fallin and and consciously and
subconsciously doesn't realize he is
free fallin or about to be what I got a
lot of free time Cameron lot of free
time so I feel like that song was really
the message that was being sent to Jerry
Maguire but Jerry Maguire wasn't really
hearing the message you are correct that
that my dream was that you would one day
the first person to say that but that
was that was the plan the the other joke
was that there are so many songs by the
Rolling Stones where you don't really
know the lyrics but you think you can
sing along I loved it
the other thing I thought is to be
what's the one thing you have to be able
to capture when you do a team movie you
know our younger movie what is the one
thing that has to be you know aside from
being authentic but for teens to buy
into a teen movie I think you should not
be making it so the teens will buy into
a teen movie I think it has to be a
story that's authentic and that you feel
you know it's it's when people say I'm
going to do a teen movie so you say I
think like this this year or last year
age of 17 movie where they're not making
a genre kind of movie or you know
gaining to make a movie for young people
it's about you know young characters
we're going to real star
and that's always the best and of course
it's like if it ate that's great
I thought Haley was great what do you
know woody in there like any Harrelson
yeah okay the Dan ads have like do we
have enough time do you have enough time
Cameron that I can get Mike my guys to
have one question for you okay all right
start with you time Fast Times at
Ridgemont High was Jeff Spicoli Sean
Penn was that automatic or other people
involved for that role automatic can't
even believe this happened he came in we
said okay do the part he said I'm not
gonna do the part like well you came in
to audition he said I know how to do
this part I know this character if you
want to see it
hire me and he's done nothing that we've
seen we heard he was in a movie called
bad boys it was good I can't believe it
like he left the room and we just said
let's hire him and I tried to get him to
say it like to me I thought like you
know if he doesn't say you right we're
dead
and so all the time we were filming and
coming up to the scene I would say like
Sean Sean
well actually he wanted us to call Jeff
come on it's late you're feeling good
came here you like to try that no no no
then the day came and he did the scene
and he made such a meal out of thing you
we kind of looked at each other like oh
my god did we make the right move or
what this guy is like the maestro so he
literally bluffed his way into the park
and and none of us were able to call him
Sean until the day he finished the
character Seaton your question for
cameras amazing your nickname for my
Sean DeNiro
I'm in character here mr. C what is the
one story you want to tell but haven't
quite been able to figure it out yet
sort of like white whale your white
whale if you have oh well well it's
actually a script I'm finishing right
now
which I'd love to tell you what it is
maybe I can call back soon and tell you
but it's kind of been a dream project
for a long time so there's that but no I
just like to keep telling different
kinds of stories and you're not a sequel
guy I'm not a sequel guy I like that
about you thank you yeah
it's hard to recapture whatever it is
you know I thought JJ Abrams did a
really good job like doing his Star Wars
turn but generally it's pretty hard to
kind of reunite people and have the same
effect pretty rare and he can
retroactively Lee destroy what you loved
about the original so sometimes you just
have to walk away we appreciate you
spending time Cameron I'm sure the call
came out of nowhere like wait what did
somebody die why am I getting a phone
call to be on to talk about Jerry
Maguire no I heard about it and I was
like dan dan interviewed when Glen is
you know Dan's part of the DNA of Jerry
Maguire by uh by planning by proxy with
Glen and I just thought it'd be to be a
part of the planning thank you though
and thanks for everything that you've
given us you know it's hard to turn on
Direct TV without going oh there's
another movie oh there's another movie
they're awesome Thank You Cameron we
appreciate it the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience